but we begin with breaking news
overnight a troubling crime in North
Carolina police say multiple power
stations were shot up in an act of
sabotage that knocked out power to
thousands of homes in near freezing
temperatures the FBI is now involved it
happened in Moore County in the in the
central part of the state Mark Strassman
is in North Carolina Mark good morning
good morning nade with temperatures here
in the 30s tens of thousands of people
are without power here in Moore County
those houses have to be cold several
dozen have found warmth in the shelter
behind me officials here say that the
outages began Saturday night after two
power substations were intentionally
targeted and damaged by gunfire this was
intentional Crews found signs of
vandalism multiple pieces of equipment
were damaged repairs may go on for days
the Moore County Sheriff said
authorities have not determined a motive
but that the attack attack was targeted
more than 33 thousand individuals spent
Sunday night in the dark and the cold
with temperatures last night dropping to
34 degrees and Duke Energy officials
warned that restoring power could take
days making life very challenging
possibly until Thursday a state of
emergency has been declared here County
Schools will be closed today and the FBI
is now helping local and state officials
trying to figure out who did this and
why
that's the question mark why makes no
sense thank you very much